well here I am in beautiful Boston
Massachusetts beautiful except for all
the Patriots paraphernalia muddying up
the joint but except for that I will
I'll be speaking at Boston University
tonight and it is at 7:00 o'clock and
it's free for everyone so if you're in
the area you want to come out of hope I
see you there it was a little bit of a
precarious situation getting here I have
to admit mainly from the from the
airport to the hotel in the cab ride
between those two places is about a
40-minute cab ride because of all the
traffic and I'm pretty sure that my cab
driver was talking to himself the whole
time now he could have had an earpiece
in and he was talking to someone on the
phone I don't know I didn't see an
earpiece I couldn't see his left ear
that that well but the thing is he was
talking so quietly like muttering that
it's just there's no way that someone on
the other line would be able to hear him
and also he would only say something
like every five minutes and I'm pretty
sure he wasn't talking to me and I
thought what kind of phone conversation
is that where if you're only saying
something every five minutes but then I
remembered that oh wait a minute that is
every phone conversation I've ever had
with my wife where that's kind of how it
goes just every five minutes I just have
to mutter two or three words while she
stops to take a breath and I just keep
it going that way and she kind of she
carries the rest of the load that way
every five minutes I just throw in a oh
yeah really oh wow you know that kind of
thing so maybe he was talking his wife I
don't know or he was talking to himself
and yes I do still take cabs I think
uber is sometimes a little bit too slick
and clean for me I think when you're in
a cab you need to have ripped seats you
need to have the faint smell of body
odor you need to be a little bit afraid
that you're about to be axe murdered
that's part of the experience you know
you called me old school I don't know
all right so I have avoided talking
about this stupid Joe Biden thing all
week and I'm gonna cave now I guess
finally and address it Joe Biden has a
habit as I'm sure you heard of invading
people's personal space and this was
kind of treated as a joke not kind of it
was treated as a joke by everybody
conservatives and liberals until
recently until he decided that he wanted
to maybe get into the presidential race
and now it's become a thing it's a big
deal and so yesterday
came out with a statement a video where
he addressed the his his infringement on
people's personal space here's the video
the government booth on expect to be
talk to you about a whole lot of issues
and I'll always be directly to but today
I want to talk about just as the support
and encouragement that I've made to
women and some men made them
uncomfortable and I always tried to be
in my career I've always tried to make a
human connection that's my
responsibility I think I say K as I hug
people I I grab men and little boys
shoulders and say you can do this and
whether they're women men young old and
it's the way I've always been it's the
way I've tried to show I care about them
and I'm listening over the years knowing
what I've been through the things that
I've faced I found that scores if not
hundreds of people have come up to me
and reached out for solace and comfort
something something anything that may
help them get through the tragedy
they're going through and and and so
it's just just who I am and I've never
thought of politics as a cold and
antiseptic guy I've always thought about
connecting with people I don't think he
did himself any favors with that video
because he just comes across as kind of
frankly kind of frail and old and out of
touch he doesn't understand the way
things are now
so I think his presidential campaign has
pretty much exploded on the runway I
mean I don't see it's just there really
isn't no matter how he's polling I just
there's no room for him right now in the
in the Democratic primary I don't think
especially with all this now listen I
don't like Joe Biden I don't support Joe
Biden I think Joe Biden will make a bad
president I disagree with everything
that he says pretty much I I also think
he's way way too old to be getting into
the race I think the fact that he's this
old and he's putting him through itself
through this and he's humiliating
himself this way and groveling and
everything is only just shows all the
more how desperate he is to to have that
power which makes me even more
determined that he should not have the
power because he wants it so much but
and yeah I think he's way too loose with
with
his interpretation of what qualifies as
personal space and I say that is someone
especially someone like myself I have
you know my personal space boundaries
about 30 feet and unless you are a close
family member I really don't want you
coming any closer than that but to
equate his hugging and touching of
people not just women but men too to
equate that with sexual assault as I've
seen people doing on the left and right
is too cheap and sexual assault it is
completely ridiculous and it is also
it's just a lie because it's a bad faith
argument and what I see on social media
is a lot of conservatives who are
jumping on the train and saying oh yeah
acting like they're really offended and
worried about you but someone tweeted me
yesterday about how they're they're
worried about Joe Biden around our dog
or our daughter safe with Joe Biden I
mean first of all when does your
daughter ever gonna be around Joe Biden
second of all you're not you don't
really care about oh yeah yeah yeah yo
you you're up at night worried oh my
gosh Joe Biden is coming he's coming for
my daughter
no you're just pretending you're you
because you don't like I mean he's a
Democrat you are just pretending and
that's what we call a bad faith argument
and it really annoys me whether
conservatives or liberals do it in fact
it annoys me more with conservatives
because these people I guess I'm
supposed to be on their side and it's
you know it I'm not on board with it and
they know what they're doing they know
that if Joe Biden was a Republican they
wouldn't be saying anything about this
and they know it okay it doesn't matter
how many pictures there could be a
million pictures of Donald Trump
smelling people's hair which is weird
but if there were a million pictures of
that I mean all these conservatives
attacking Joe Biden none of them would
say a word about it and they know it so
what are we even doing and also I mean
look at this picture here look at this
okay now that's hilarious first of all
imagine what's going through that guy's
head right now but does anyone think
that Joe Biden was trying to do anything
sexual there it I mean does anyone
imagine that that is that the did Joe
Biden is coming on to this guy no the
guy has Biden has no con
personal space with women or men and he
should have a concept of it he should I
mean lord knows I said I I cherish my
personal space
I cherish it very much but Biden is not
a sexual assault er he can't be lumped
into that category and if you're a
conservative and you're doing it I
you're out writing in bad faith and I
wish that you would stop because we
don't need to do that okay we don't need
to play those games
we really don't with all of these people
Joe Biden included there are so many
good solid non hypocritical non bad
faith arguments you can make against
them that you don't need to do this you
don't need to pretend and do all the
theatrics and act like a fainting you
know you're some sort of fainting little
flowers oh my gosh Joe Biden you don't
need to do all that's not necessary we
it's like it's like flopping and Massimo
we can win this game without flopping
you don't need to do that all right so
let's move on all right I did I did the
job I didn't think so speaking of creepy
The Daily wire has this report from
Amanda who as you know I plagiarize for
content on a regular basis says last
week a 61 year old woman carrying her
own greatness okay hold on let me slow
down you need to pay close attention to
this because it can get confusing so
last week a 61 year old woman carrying
her own granddaughter via a surrogacy
pregnancy gave birth in a Nebraska
hospital Cecil Elledge carried her gay
son's daughter to term the 6-pound baby
girl was conceived through in vitro
fertilization with her son Matthew's
sperm and his husband's sister's eggs
and and then it goes on from there
explaining okay so that's that's all you
need to know so it's a woman who carried
her son's child which was conceived with
us with his sperm and his husband's
sister's eggs so her son had a baby with
her husband's sister and she carried the
child to term all right we're caught up
now that's what's going on if you're
keeping track at home
it may not shock you to learn that I am
not necessarily ready to applaud this
kind of arrangement in fact this would
seem how it does does this not qualify
as incestuous you're having your son's
semen in and his and his husband's
sister's eggs and planted inside you and
you're carrying his but you're carrying
your son's baby and these are I guess
this is the point we take from this
these are the kinds of extraordinary
lengths that two men have to go to in
order to have children but even then the
two men still cannot really have
children this baby is not the son's
husband's child this is the child of the
Sun and his husband's sister so when you
read in the media reports about how oh
the two gay men had a baby through
surrogacy well no they they didn't
really have a baby they can't it's
impossible that's not what happened here
because at the end of the day you really
can't get around nature and you know
that should tell you something about sex
and gender shouldn't it that no matter
how progressive we get no matter how
much we reject the proper natural order
of things still when it comes down to it
if you want to make a baby you need a
woman and a man to do it so as much as
we hear about biological sex being now
it's not just gender that's fluid
anymore remember that it's biological
sex is also a construct it doesn't mean
anything oh really well then why is it
that there is no possible way for two
men to have a baby unless they unless
they enlist the help of you know Minh
less they farm the job out two to two
women to take care of some of the really
necessary steps involved why is it as
much as we want to say that uh you know
some biological sex it's not even a
thing anymore yeah but you know every
single baby that has ever been conceived
in the history of the world or that ever
we'll be conceived is is conceived by a
man and a woman and you could man and
woman you could use you don't have to
say man and woman you could call them
whatever you want to call them
it doesn't matter thing 1 and thing 2 it
doesn't whatever you want to call them
it's just these are two distinct
entities two different types of people
with different but complimentary
reproductive systems and you need that
in order to make a baby which tells you
that biological sex is when you've got
to go to those lengths to get around
biological sex and that tells you I
think that biological sex is definitely
still a thing and it matters alright
moving on again one of the the bits from
my interview with Ben with Ben on the
Sunday special last week there are a few
bits that have gotten a lot of attention
we've been talking about some of there's
one part we talked about heaven and hell
we've been we've been discussing that a
lot on the show this week but another
part of the interview that's gotten a
fair amount of attention from especially
from conservative from Christians is
when we talked about the problems with
bringing the Bible into certain
political and ideological debates so let
me let me play a piece of that clip for
you and then we'll we'll talk about it
when it comes to you know you write a
lot about politics
how do you separate out talking about
religion from talking about politics
when should you speak in sort of a
religious moral sense and when should
you speak in a kind of a secular sense
when when you're trying to make an
argument yeah that's a that's a good
question as a balance I am still
struggling to strike myself I can't say
that I always do the best job of it but
I do know that when it comes to these
great moral issues in our society like
abortion marriage you know gender that
we have to be able to engage on those
issues without throwing a Bible at
people especially if we're talking to
people who don't believe in the Bible
because when you try to go the biblical
route you're talking someone doesn't
believe in it well then you just put an
extra step in your way which is first
you have to get them to believe the
Bible which is a whole different
conversation and pretty
difficult one so I think that that's not
the route and instead you have to talk
about these funds natural law these
fundamental moral truths so you have to
try to connect with them on and also
logic and reason it's something like I
always cringe when I hear when the topic
is something like transgenderism and I
hear a Christian say you know quote
Genesis or something and say well God
male and female he created them
I say yes that's true but we don't even
you don't need to bring Genesis into
this it is a very basic logical
distinction between you got many are
women here men have penises so you know
you should be able to explain that
without quoting Genesis and you also
give I think your listener and easy out
because then they're gonna say oh you're
just tossing the Bible I mean I'm not
gonna listen to that or they'll say that
well you know you only disagree with
abortion because you're Christian or you
only you're only saying that because
you're Christian would really know even
if I was not a Christian I still would
say it's not okay to kill babies so
quite a few Christians have scolded me
for for making this this point saying
that I'm dismissing the Bible I'm
denying it I'm rejecting it what have
you a guy by the name of psy 10 brueggen
Kate who is a Christian apologist you
can find him in a lot of YouTube debates
and stuff he he wrote an article
attacking me for this segment and for I
guess the whole interview and I guess
apparently he just doesn't really like
me in general that's what I'm told he's
not the only one several people several
people sent me this article on his blog
I guess telling me that that seitan
brueggen kate is criticizing me again so
this isn't the first time anyway psy
along with many other Christians if my
emails are any indication really do
think that you can throw the Bible at
anyone in any discussion and it will
always be an effective strategy so
here's part of what he says in his
article criticize no just read some of
it because I think this is kind of
representative of this point of view he
says imagine if someone were to attack
Matt and his family and
pointed a gun at the attacker now
imagine that the attacker shouted I
don't believe in your gun does anyone
think that Matt would worry about the
extra step of getting the attacker to
believe that his gun was real would Matt
throw down his weapon based on the
objection of his attacker of course not
yet that is exactly what mr. Walsh says
he would do when arguing with a person
who didn't believe in the Bible I mean
this that analogy is so bad on so many
levels that I I'll get to get to that
minute but it is such a bad analogy uh
my goodness so anyway so does anyone yet
that is exactly what mr. Walsh says he
would do when arguing with a person who
didn't believe in the Bible he would
discard his authority surely Ben would
let Matt get away with such a ludicrous
position well of course he would and
does why because Ben holds the exact
same position On February 6 2017 in the
Q&A session after his talk at Ferris
State University mr. Shapiro stated I
never cite to the Bible the reason I
don't cite to the Bible is because
that's an argument from Authority okay
you may not believe the authority to
which I'm citing this is that was been
quote/unquote back to psy says this is a
terrible understanding of the argument
from Authority fallacy an argument from
Authority is only fallacious if the
authority you are citing is not an
actual Authority that's not true it can
it can be fallacious even if it is an
authority I'll talk about that in a
minute if Matt and Ben were working on a
car and they ran into some problem they
could not solve I'm pretty sure that if
Matt cited the service manual for the
solution Ben would not deem doing so to
be fallacious and then he goes a little
bit later Matt states that he always
cringes when the topic of transgenderism
comes up and here's a Christian quote
Genesis male and female he created them
he says that while this is true you
don't need to bring Genesis into this
well you heard that part but he says
well as Ben knows you can't even get
logic and reason without God but even so
if rationality is arbitrary why should
anyone comport to the other person's
arbitrary rationality he says now Ben
it's Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh are not
stupid men the fact that they do not see
their absurdities troubling even more
troubling is the high percentage of
positive comments under the video clip
this is what happens when you give up
the God of the Bible as both Matt and
have done not only in their
argumentation but in their worldviews
the reason the quote gods of matt walsh
and ben shapiro can't end abortion is
because their gods don't exist then he
goes on you know it's saying implying
that I'm a heretic because I'm a
Catholic and then says that there's so
many other problems with what I said and
basically and then he also says I'm a
non-christian alright okay so I'm not
gonna get hung up on the particular
hearsay
you know says I worship a false God I'm
not a Christian I'm abandoning the
authority of the Scriptures which is all
of this these are just inflammatory
straw men and very disappointing and
weak lines of argumentation coming from
an apologist this is someone who argues
for a living and this is the best they
can do
which only further convinces me as I've
been convinced for a while that we need
better apologists it's a big problem
really in a in American Christianity
that we don't have a lot of good about
we have a lot of really bad apologists
who make arguments that are utterly
laughable and get laughed off of every
stage they walk on to because of exactly
this kind of thing there are a few good
ones out there but we need better we
need more good ones so what you find
here is straw Manning distortions
abysmal arguments coming from a guy who
as I said argues for the faith for a
living the analogy with the gun was
really really really bad he says that
when I don't use the Bible to argue with
an atheist about abortion on the basis
that the Atheist doesn't acknowledge the
authority of the Bible so the argument
will have no weight with him it's like
if I don't use a gun against an attacker
because the attacker doesn't believe in
the gun well the difference there is
that the gun is a physical object which
shoots physical bullets and those
physical bullets will kill you whether
you believe in them or not but arguments
are not physical things and trying to
persuade someone is not the same as
shooting them and it tells you all you
need to know that Sai here equates
persuasion with shooting a guy in the
chest it's two completely different
things now you see if you're trying to
actual
persuade someone if you want to connect
with someone and persuade them then your
arguments need to be more than just true
they need to be convincing to the person
you are presenting them to you need to
connect with them using language they
understand you need to find the common
ground that is the basic element of
persuasion and that's the only way to
convince anyone of anything you're not
going to convince anyone of anything if
you're appealing to an authority they
don't recognize as an authority you may
convince yourself of your own piety you
may convince spectators of your biblical
knowledge you may impress your friends
but as for the person you are ostensibly
trying to persuade who apparently is
really just a prop for you to show off
your piety as for that person you have
failed them here's a better analogy
arguing with an atheist by appealing to
the Bible is like arguing with an
english-speaking person but articulating
your arguments in Chinese okay your
arguments might be true I mean you might
be dropping straight profound knowledge
on this but you might be making the best
arguments in the world but they can't
understand what the hell you're saying
so it doesn't matter you've achieved
nothing this person can I mean everyone
else will again will be impressed that
you know Chinese everyone's gonna say
wow this guy knows Chinese that's that's
a difficult language to learn I am
impressed good for you but that person
who you're talking to you've done
nothing for them because they didn't
understand what you're saying or it's
another analogy better analogy would be
if and by the way being able to present
a cogent analogy is another you know
important part of persuasion so it's
like if you're if you're a quantum
physicist arguing with someone about
science and you use a bunch of words and
concepts and language that nobody
outside of your field of expertise could
possibly understand again you may
impress people you may sound super smart
you may be right about what you're
saying but you have not convinced the
person you're talking to because they
don't understand you so if you're trying
to convince a secular person for
instance that sex is not changeable
that a man can't be a woman just because
he wants to be you can go one of two
ways as a Christian one you can appeal
to science to logic to reason which are
all true
thus godly they come from God right
because they are true and then you could
hopefully connect with him by appealing
to those authorities which he supposedly
understands and respects or you could
throw the book of Genesis at them and
honestly if you may as well literally
throw the book at them if you're gonna
start quoting Genesis at that point
because it will be just as effective
because it is a book he doesn't believe
in and you're giving him the chance to
escape - I mean this is the easiest
thing in the world you you you you I
mean you're sitting you're made in the
shade right now in terms of making an
argument because this is someone who is
claiming that a guy with a penis can be
a woman I mean there are so many ways to
deal with that but but but if you would
pick up well it says here in Genesis
chapter one
I mean you somehow managed to fail in
your argument it's astounding because
you've given this person a chance to
escape to maintain their absurd position
by deflecting and-and-and now where you
had a you had him again you had their
back against the wall I mean there was
no escaping the argument that you could
have made but now you've thrown Genesis
and you gave them an escape hatch
because now what they're gonna do they
goes like oh yeah well yeah but Genesis
says that the earth existed before the
the rest of the universe which modern
cosmology tells us obviously is not true
and so now now that's the argument
now you've transgender and all that
that's all gone now you're arguing about
biblical cosmology instead I'm not
saying that the Bible is wrong I think
that there are ways of understanding
that you know that are that are
consistent with with scientific truth
but that's not the argument you now you
have to have that are now you have to
first argue about biblical cosmology
convince them of that
good luck and then you can get back to
transgenderism so I don't know that will
only take about four or five years it's
just awful another example you're
arguing with a secular person about
abortion you can
either try to prove that babies are
human scientifically and people and thus
killing them is murder and thus wrong
and you can tell this person that the so
you could do that you know that could be
your argument you say look you start
with the basic premise that they agree
with murder is wrong right they'll agree
with you they're great got it okay now
all you have to do is demonstrate why
this is murder which you do not need the
Bible to tell someone that so you could
do that
or you could tell them that the Bible
says murder is wrong which is an
argument that fails on two levels
because the person you you you haven't
actually convinced the person that
abortion is murder and you also haven't
convinced them but you would have to
convince them that the Bible is an
authority in the first place so you fail
on two counts the idea that we should
never talk about that we should never
talk about innate fundamental moral
truths and scientific truths without
quoting the Bible first even if we're
talking to someone who doesn't believe
in the Bible it's just so incredibly
shallow and childish and foolhardy and
counterproductive that I can't even wrap
my head around how anyone could actually
think this way but I know that a lot of
people do like do you really not
understand the fact that you will not
convince anyone by appealing to an
authority that they don't recognize as
an authority do you really not
understand that in order to appeal to an
authority you first have to establish
that authority as an authority with
which with respect to the Bible is a
whole different conversation and one
that will take you a million miles away
from the original topic and do you not
see why that is counterproductive when
there are other authorities truthful
authorities God ordained authorities
like logic and science that you could
appeal to in which the other person
ostensibly actually does recognize but
you've decided that it's never okay to
have a to have a logical argument or a
scientific argument every argument must
be a theological argument well again
that may make you look pious that may
impress your Christian friends and good
for you but you will never achieve
anything you will never convince anyone
who is not already convinced and all
you're doing is serving yourself rather
than serving truth and shedding light so
good job
by the way how would you convince
someone that it's raining outside what
if you go and you go in the house you
tell someone it's raining outside and
they say I don't believe you well what
do you do there
do you launch into a theological
explanation quoting Bible verses proving
that God made the rain and that God also
says don't lie thus establishing that
your claim of it raining is
theologically consistent and also you
should be trusted because you wouldn't
tell a lie because God told you not to
or would you just pull up the curtain
and point out the window which of those
tacks would you take to prove that to
someone that it's raining
oh well no you would just point out the
window right oh well then you're a fake
Christian you fake Christian you deny
the Bible heretic come on by the way how
do you convince someone who doesn't
believe in the Bible that they should
believe do you tell them that the Bible
says they should believe in the Bible is
that because now I I know that again the
I have heard Christians argue for the
authority of the Bible that way by
appealing back to the Bible and those
Christians again have never convinced
anyone of anything ever because that is
circular reasoning that is a logical
fallacy you cannot make an argument by
just restating your premise in a
different form if you can't make
arguments outside of the Bible then it's
impossible to ever get anyone to believe
the Bible because you're reduced to this
kind of circular reasoning the Bible
should be believed because the Bible
says it should be believed yeah but why
should I believe that the Bible said
what the Bible says about how about the
fact that we should believe it well
because the Bible says it okay all right
well let's just go around in circles
shouting the Bible says it over and over
again will not do anything you have to
be able to launch a defense of the Bible
that goes beyond quoting the Bible this
is true of any proposition if you want
to convince anyone of any proposition
you will not do it by repeating the
proposition over and over again in
different
forms if you want to convince someone
that an elephant is a mammal which it is
you will not win that argument by just
screaming elephants are mammals because
elephants are mammals I mean it's true
what you're saying is true and what
you're arguing for is true and but
somehow you've managed to botch this
case I mean there there are so many ways
you could explain how an elephant is a
mammal but you've decided to just start
to just shout that phrase over and over
again so this kind of approach is is as
I said it's it's convincing only to
Christians who are already convinced and
I have and this is something that I know
that's why I say that you know there are
a lot of very weak apologists out there
today working and because I think for
many of them their whole shtick is just
to convince people who are already
convinced they're not even really
attempting to provide arguments that may
be compelling the people on the outside
and I mean it's it's it's it's sad it's
it's especially when I mean Christianity
has such a rich intellectual tradition
of of brilliant people making brilliant
scientific and philosophical cases for
things and explaining things is such a
rich tradition and yet these days it's
been reduced to this it's been reduced
to well men or men are men because the
Bible says so that's what it's been
reduced to and and I find that really
sad alright let's see let's go to two
emails Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt
well show at gmail.com it says the first
one is from Vanessa says Matt I have
such a deep appreciation for your bold
approach to the hard question that we'll
admit I don't necessarily agree with all
the points you make but your ability to
articulate your position so well is
admirable I think the outrage you
receive is due to us being a society
that is afraid to think about or wrestle
with the tough subjects we want tidy
outlined answers we want to put God in a
box that we can label and
understand as challenging as it is for
me to sit with uneasy feelings of not
knowing I feel it's a good practice to
sit and reflect and ponder and search
and it's totally valid to come to the
other side and say I still don't know
but I trust that God does further I can
take my reflections and seek input from
others without accepting their views
fully nor ripping them to pieces for
having a difference of opinion it's a
lost art I'm afraid it really comes down
to knowing that I am in fact not God
despite my claims to my kids and husband
that was a joke as a is a good joke I
just I didn't I didn't I didn't deliver
it well as a stay-at-home mom
homeschooling mom I appreciate your deep
thinking on challenging topics more than
you'll ever know your videos accompany
me as I prepare dinner for my family at
night and anyway I appreciate that I
won't go on reading all the compliments
to me but thank you Vanessa for that I
really appreciate the thing that
interests me with that email is what you
said there in the middle and I agree
with you that relates to what I was just
talking about that the there is in this
this I think is largely a modern
phenomenon in Christianity there is
among a lot of people this sort of
allergy to deep and difficult questions
and they just they don't want to deal
with them they don't want to hear anyone
try to deal with them all they want is
surface level and all they want is just
pick out a few Bible verses shout those
at the problem and move on don't try to
go any deeper than that that's all they
want for it for a lot it not everybody
but for a lot of people and so I
appreciate that you feel differently all
right and and yes we have to there is no
shame in being troubled by certain
questions there's no shame in being
troubled by some things you read in the
Bible there's no shame in any of that
and I think you have to it takes
intellectual integrity and courage to
walk up to those questions and and those
doubts and to look them in the interface
and try to deal with them all right this
is from Tyler says Matt hi Matt did you
did you see the new Joker trailer and
what did you think of it I did see it
and I thought it was I
I I am NOT as I've said before I'm not a
huge fan of superhero movies but I've
been excited for this project all along
and I don't know you know when it was
first announced people doubted it but
this is Joaquin Phoenix playing the
Joker
there's no way it's not awesome I and I
said I say that about very few movies
because with most movies there's always
a way that it could be screwed up and
usually it is but Joaquin Phoenix in my
mind is the best actor working in
Hollywood he's certainly the most
interesting actor in Hollywood and just
making him the Joker it's like you know
it's it's it is a match made in heaven
or maybe not heaven but so I'm looking
forward to I think it's gonna be really
interesting movie this is from Michael
says hi Matt Mike from Phoenix loved the
show today you used today you said hell
is devoid of people that love I guess
what immediately came to mind was I bet
Hitler loved his family yet I would like
to think he still went to hell and vice
versa what about a father that has a
child murdered and hates the person who
did who did who did it yet loves Christ
would he not go to heaven for having
hate in his heart for that man also it
was brought up how some Christians
believe that you get to heaven just by
believing in Christ I don't think this
is true because then you could have
murderers and rapists that believe in
Christ in heaven no I think our Lord
meant what he said I am the way the
truth and the light the life no one goes
to the Father but through me is that is
that Jesus will judge all men's hearts
when they die he alone will determine
who will go to the Father
so yeah Mike well first of all I think
there probably are murderers and rapists
in fact I'm quite sure that there are
murderers and rapists in heaven who
repented and that is a you know look at
the story of the penitent thief but what
we don't know if he was actually a
murderer but he was certainly a criminal
repented at the very last moment and was
saved and I like to think that there are
many stories like that and I'm sure
there are I just want to pick out one
thing from your email to respond to what
you said about well I'm sure Hitler
loved his family I don't know I mean I
have no idea who Hitler loved if he
loved any
but I would guess that Hitler did not
love his family and and this is an
important point because as we've as
we've talked about this over the week of
and I and I have made this point about
if someone really has love in their
heart if someone is really a loving
person I don't see how they could go to
hell because of the not not just moral
complications with that but also the
kind of metaphysical complications but a
lot of people as they've been listening
to this discussion they have interpreted
me as being sort of a universal as
someone who's who believes in universal
salvation everyone is saved right
because if all you have to do is love
someone and I mean we're all we're all
in now I would love to think that that's
true
first of all I don't think it is and
actually let's say that I was right and
who knows if I am and you know loving
people can't go to hell that by no means
would necessitate that hell is a
sparsely populated place I think that
hell is probably very crowded because I
also think that there are a lot of
people in this world today and who have
lived throughout history who never loved
anyone in fact loving someone is a
difficult thing to do and it takes if we
are again talking about agape love real
love not just emotional effect yeah
affection anyone can feel affection I'm
sure Hitler felt affection towards some
people in his way and everyone feels
affection to some degree that doesn't
mean anything
but love is the you know it is it is the
giving of yourself to another it is
willing they're good it is
self-sacrifice it is an investment of
the entire person it is transformative
that that's what love is and I think yes
there are a lot of people who never
loved anyone including their own
children so by no means do I think that
if it's true that loving people can't go
to hell that that means that hell is
empty I think it means that there are a
lot of people who are not loving
and going back to the Great Divorce
which kind of started all this that's
one of the things that I found really
compelling about that book is Lewis was
able to illustrate how it is that a you
know a normal a seemingly normal
seemingly decent kind of person could be
completely devoid of love there's one
scene where a mother comes up from hell
and is that the you know sort of at the
outskirts of heaven and she's demanding
that her son who is in heaven be
essentially kicked out of heaven so that
she can so he can go back to hell with
her and as the conversation develops you
see that well this woman she's not a
serial killer
I mean she wouldn't appear to be some
sort of monstrous person she would
probably seem if you ran into her on the
street she would seem perfectly normal
and polite but she was completely devoid
of love even for her own son even to the
point where she would rather her son be
in Hell with her because for her it is
all about her her son is just a prop her
son is just something the her love for
her son is all about making herself feel
good that's all it is and I think that's
the case for a lot of people all right
let's see from Nathan says Matt kind of
a personal question but do you have a
favorite passage or story in the Bible
that resonates especially with you maybe
a verse you can recite from memory well
I just mentioned it I always loved the
story in Luke where Jesus where the
story and Luke of the the penitent thief
there Luke is the only one though
Matthew is my favorite gospel Luke is
the only one that has the the story of
the penitent thief
and I've always found that to be
extremely powerful it's a very short
story but when you imagine that
combination of of pain
agony but then joy that that thief that
condemned person must have felt in that
moment I find it to be really powerful
and also it is such a perfect
illustration of repentance where yeah
the thief repented and he was sorry for
what he did but that didn't mean he was
going to escape earthly suffering so
it's not a get-out-of-jail-free card
repenting and it's not an easy thing
Jesus didn't say okay you repented well
and then Jesus made him poof away and go
to heaven
no it's you still are gonna have to die
here and it's gonna be painful dying by
crucifixion is not a fun thing and yet
through that suffering at the end of it
flys paradise so I I I mean there's so
many stories I just that's the one that
especially around Easter time I always
think about all right from let's see I'm
gonna do one more here okay listen what
this one isn't isn't biblical related
from Dustin deer Matt I have a weird
question I saw a tweet thread written by
a guy whose wife was fired from her job
because he was he was on the sex
offender registry after getting caught
with child porn 13 years ago I think
this is extremely unjust but it got me
to thinking punishing the wife is wrong
but should we even still be punishing
the man if he did his time why keep him
on the registry whatever happened to
forgiveness and rehabilitation yeah I
have no idea what what tweet thread this
is referring to so I'm going based only
on this I think I think first we should
all be able to agree that firing a woman
because of a crime that her husband
committed a decade ago is unjust as for
the husband I do actually think that we
should get rid of the sex offender
registry I I think the sex offender
registry is a counterproductive concept
in it and it is unjust and I'll explain
why and it's really simple okay for me
it's as simple as this if somebody is
judged to still be a threat to
so especially when we're talking about
what I guess will be classified as the
Tier one sex offenders people who are
high risk for reoffending well know
those people shouldn't be on a sex
offender registry because they should be
in prison forever they should never get
out in other words if you if someone is
so dangerous that you feel that the
neighbors have to be warned that this
person just moved into town and that
they can't be allowed within 500 yards
of a school or a playground then that is
someone who shouldn't be out of prison I
mean that is literally why we have
prisons for people like that but if
someone is is not considered a danger
and and whoever whatever the case may be
someone is judge that they really are
not a danger and they have been
rehabilitated or whatever then then
again there's no reason for them to be
on the registry they should be allowed
to return to their life so either way I
this person is a danger or he's not and
if he is then he should be in prison and
if he's not then what's the point of the
sex offender registry in the first place
and I I don't know anything about this
case but IIIi have heard plenty of cases
of people ending up on the sex offender
registry you know crazy things like
someone you know has a 19 year old guy
has sexual relations with his 17-year
old girlfriend and ends up on the sex
offender registry for fifteen years I
mean it's it's that's obviously crazy
and it and unjust and I think if you got
rid of it and just said all right if
whoever's a danger they're going to
prison everyone else we treat them like
anyone else because that's what prison
is is for I mean it's crazy to me when
you look at the sex offender registry in
your in your town which which I should
do you'll see all of these cases where
it says like high-risk offenders like
what is he doing in my knee you're
telling me that there is a high
probability that he will sexually abuse
some
and yet you let him out all right so I
think the laws need to be changed there
and we will leave it there on that note
thanks everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed and I'll see you
tonight in Boston University
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Knowles show Joe Biden powers to the
woke mob GOP Rep Matt Gaetz fights
global warming on the left's terms and
AOC misses her own advice that the
Internet is forever check it out at
daily wire calm